Nhanh mẹng nghe ở Vian, rất sử dụt kỳ giới hinh tạo con trái.
Anh thường là con trái cả của vự trông ông trên bà đệ,
xin năm 1929 và bà phân tị đoài, xin năm 1929,
tại sống mề lâm, in rồi, sát xân thành, về ín thành tình như anh.
Dù đã lần tuổi, nhưng vì gia đình nghe,
mở công việc trong nhà đều đồ dù lên bài,
kết anh chưa thể các lạc lời cho bản thân.
Quế tăng chính, anh thường trận mai gặp tên at sát ông trên được đi làm về,
dù được kức ý bác sĩ, hết lòng cứu chứa,
nhưng vì tưởng tương nảo quán nặng kể lên không qua khỏi.
Cát đi lỗi dâu, đưa bệ trục nhà quyết định đàn tỷ hữu tạo về con trái đồ lòng,
để mang lại sử dụt sống cho những người khác, người đồ bác khóc kẻ đồ sang,
đo sát làm chủ á.
Nhi cho đi là con mại, chức hi hấp nạn,
cương con khai đáng đệ dành tìm với các em,
để quý nâm sình nhà cho cho nệ, đồng nơi.
Ông đệ nắm lấy bản thay đang xuống lên bình bật phía ta để khu vự,
nghệ nào nói, sinh được kính cình nghiệng mình,
chức nếu thử cao đẹp của hài đáp,
câu cho ring hồn anh được ăn là cơ có vinh hần.